good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast I know what you're
thinking man Jackie looks hairy today
but Jackie is not here ben has filled in
very last minute for her we are very
excited to have you thank you so much
for the years you are so welcome
it was such great timing Jackie called
me this morning she had a dental moment
emergency and me and that happened to me
at a bris together for our dear friends
Ben and Margene congratulations by the
way
so we got some breakfast and now we're
here I've never been up for so many
hours before the toasts like usually I
just wake up get ready and go but we got
up we have to be at the bris by 8 we got
there at 8:30 but the Brits was called
for 8:00
oh yes on the car I said I said let's
get there at 8:00 Ben was like no nobody
gets to a bris at a it says 8 o'clock
you think maybe the moil schmooze is
maybe he tells a jobber those who don't
know a bris it's a ceremonial cutting of
the foreskin for all Jewish babies it
happens 8 days after they're born the
moil is the rabbi who is the caller he
does the cutting the snipping he doesn't
and then the baby yeah yeah it's like
it's so quiet in a bris like while
they're cutting cuz nobody can really
see what's going on so they're cutting
and then all of a sudden you know what
happened cuz the baby goes it's
literally this week it [ __ ] hurts I
imagine yeah but so we get there 8:20
very appropriate 8:30 whatever over
wasn't over cuz then they have a
breakfast afterwards so we got there for
the breakfast which was good but we miss
that yeah we did which was sad but also
I think Chris's are sad like the baby's
in pain and I don't I wasn't that upset
that we missed it
it is sad yeah you remember your bris
well where was it I don't remember you
can't remember you're eight days old do
you miss your foreskin of course every
day no honestly foreskins are actually
it's controversial what you're watching
today I'm just gonna say for me I enjoy
not having a foreskin yeah I covered
this it for me I enjoy not having a
foreskin it's a it contributes to bed
hygiene you you'd think but people will
also say the other yeah that's true that
it's fine that we're not living like in
the medieval times where like nobody can
like use a bar soap in their foreskin
I don't know how deep we should go into
this conversation but apparently you can
be quite hygienic and still have a
foreskin but then I would just prefer
not to have one I think that my Schmidt
I think my schmucky looks far better
this is without trying to be politically
correct I think that my schmucky looks
far better is there a part in the Bible
where someone takes their foreskin off
with a rock what yeah it's part that is
not possible
no he like takes a rock and takes his
foreskin off it's a thing that sounds
like pure torture
biblical taste man things are crazy yeah
women were having children at the age of
120 see but it makes sense that
biblically you would remove your
foreskin for hygienic purposes because
what if like you're in the desert in
like a couple of like pieces of sand Oh
toast I got stuck in your foreskin and
then you have a sandy foreskin and all
of a sudden you're known forever is
sandy foreskin sounds like the name of
like a Jewish retiring focus oh you know
my cousin sandy foreskin oh well thank
you for joining me today I'm so let me
talk about foreskins you know I don't
think Jackie's the type of girl who just
talks about foreskins you know no but
she collects them we're gonna deliver
the Fast Five I just a fast five -
Jackie usually does it it's really hard
like not that much happens between today
and yesterday and I tried to pick
stories that I think you could speak to
more and I told Ben the stories uh right
before we started he goes you're not
gonna talk about how Emma Stone is
engage kids so such a cute moment on
Instagram her and her fiance they're
like this with the ring she is uh
engaged to a writer for us an L that's
all so I don't know if he's like
necessarily famous cuz he's like 40,000
scrimp Oliver's but he's successful you
know it's just as soon I was so
confusing you don't know who does what
we don't know who doesn't do what you
don't know who in the credits does what
cuz like the most famous person on us
and I like right now is Pete Davidson
and he is never on it he wasn't even on
last episode but like he's not famous
for the right reasons
Chanel famous yeah which like the S&L
community doesn't give a [ __ ] about
trail right yeah it's like is he that
famous like for SNL I don't know like
Colin Jost is probably the most famous
know I think Kenan Thompson oh yeah I
mean he puts the [ __ ] I'm surprised he
doesn't have a bad back from putting the
show on his back for five years on his
back hey man Kate McKinnon they put the
show on their back
McKennon is amazing she's a genius
hysterical do you love her you want to
marry her
yeah I mean SNL is just yeah oh my god
Will Ferrell did you guys talk about
that at all no we didn't talk about
welfare oh my god the Will Ferrell SNL
pure gold Native American scene was so
funny your hands bone-dry
okay so I think I mean told him in five
minutes but do you think whatever you
want you want to have it do you think
it's time you're gonna take a hit first
time what was that hand motion okay do
you think it's time Ben no it's your
show I don't know okay I do I think it's
time okay I don't wanna make it like a
big deal but I think it's time cool it's
time do you know that's from you just
I'm yeah oh my god you claim to have
grown up in New York I'm sorry Oh what
about the other thing the other day Ben
worked out yesterday he has not stopped
complaining that is just like you know
when you yeah there's an adjustment
period and I've never gotten over that
adjustment period I always work out the
plates and then I don't do because I get
in so much pain
we're really extending your arms
straight it's just you didn't live
method it's unimaginable yes the live
method such a great place it's just like
it is really elective torture but yeah
I've been told that I need to change my
vocabulary that it's really
self-inflicted no self help like this is
a good thing
yeah I'm calling it like torture it's
not like I'm helping myself I'm happy
that you are working out and trying to
get yourself healthy but like if I have
to listen to you complain about how much
your arms hurt like for another week I
mean my muscles they're just so big
they're so big and sore they're bulging
they're in flames just like your
foreskin they're inflamed okay so it's
time you just you don't know what it is
time is from rossum remember like on the
back of the taxi TV they always have a
commercial for Lion King and they have
yes of course
samp Rafiki going he just died yes yes
on the toast we say it is time that's
great for the best five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast okay we
have like a sound effect that does that
we don't need you to do it no thank you
and you're doing it wrong it's more like
Oh what about okay yes it's time for the
press that's our stories and like I said
it's it is time but
I would be I would be remiss I would be
devastated I would even be heartbroken
if I didn't let everyone know that
today's episode is brought to you by
titties
oh they're love one of our favorite
brands here at the morning toast we we
are strictly third love bra wearing
company for well not today but our two
hosts usually have big jugs well you've
you've little little man boobs look
third love amazing for men and women
over 14 million women have taken their
fit finder quiz today basically you
answer a few simple questions to find
your perfect bra size in 60 seconds as
someone who's been wearing bras since
age of 13 I have recently come to learn
and the most important thing when
finding a bra is knowing your correct
size and I was wearing it in correct
size pretty much since high school and
it's crazy that I found out my correct
size just by taking a quiz like not even
getting measured because I was getting
incorrectly measured in sores third love
helps you identify your breast size and
shape and then finds the perfect style
that fits your body every customer has
60 days to wear it wash it put it to the
test and if you don't love it return it
and third level wash it and donate it to
a woman in need third look it's a nice
it is I'm happy to hear that they wash
them right you never know I mean me I
got a bunch of boob sweat so their love
helps you identify I said that right
every customer has 60 days to wear it
while she ate put it to the test
their team of expert fit stylists are
dedicated to helping you find your
perfect fit they're available every day
to help via text chat or phone call and
their returns and changes are very easy
and very free it's hands-down the most
comfortable bra you own I wear the
t-shirt bra the straps do not dig into
my shoulders which is half the battle
and the underwire does not dig into my
like under armpit it's it can be really
painful like people don't understand
being a woman is so hard sometimes in
really painful third live donates all
their gently used returned brats to
women in need supporting charities in
their local San Francisco Bay Area and
across the United States so far they
have donated over 15 million dollars in
bras which is amazing so you can know
that you're doing good while also
getting your titties all perky
third love knows that there's a perfect
bra for everyone so right now they are
offering our listeners 15% off your
first order go 2/3 love.com slash
morning toast now to find your perfect
fitting bra and then get 15% off your
first purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today can't stress it
enough how important finding the right
bra is and thanks to third love my
kidneys aren't check are yours that
should be there totally our titties
aren't check are yours totally okay
great
first story is a story it's a developer
story we covered the initial breaking
news on our patreon while we were in
Utah and it was a story about Justin
Timberlake weirdly being photographed
holding hands with his co-star Alicia
Wainwright they were together I believe
in New Orleans
um his hand was also on her thigh it was
just really weird it took the world by
storm and now people have pretty much
forgotten about it but now we're talking
about again because Justin Timberlake
released a statement which I did think
was a weird PR move because I pretty
much forgotten about it it had been like
over a week I mean if you were gonna
release a statement like it should have
been then but now a week later it's like
you're just reminding us that it
happened like I had actually forgotten
about it I feel like it truly is for his
family more than it is for anybody else
I feel like just because people have
forgotten about it the internet is so
[ __ ] mean yeah and they are so
[ __ ] famous that I'm sure that
Jessica Biel and his kids are getting
some of the crazies diem yeah and like
just like nasty stuff and I'm sure that
he just wanted to publicly come forward
and sort of end this for his family well
he released a statement and it's so
funny how like times have changed
because like five years ago releasing a
statement was like what you did through
your publicist to like various media
outlets but now you just write a note on
your sous chef and screenshot it which
is so crazy and that's what he did like
even the biggest star in the world does
that isn't crazy um this is what it said
I stay away from gossip as much as I can
okay that's like a bad way to start it
because it's also not true yeah but also
it's like it's not gossip you did it
like you were just caught that's not
gossip he's acting like he's like you
know lowering himself to speak to us
sure
but for my family I feel it is important
to address recent rumors that are
hurting the people that I loved a few
weeks ago I displayed a strong lapse in
judgment but let me be clear nothing
happened between me and my co-star I
drank way too much at night and I regret
my behavior I should have known better
this is not the example I want to set
for my son I apologize to my amazing
wife and family for putting them through
such an embarrassing situation and I'm
focusing on being the best husband and
father I can be this was not that are
they lovers in this show I don't know
because it's still being filmed but I
was actually thinking that like if it
comes out to be a movie or whatever it
is and like they're making out like
we'll be able to see the chemistry like
sometimes you could tell like in mr. and
mrs. Smith Angelina Jolie and Brad Pitt
like you knew they were [ __ ] on stage
and [ __ ] behind the scenes totally I
just think like I don't know it's very
Shady but if he's in
character and like they are like maybe
they were hearse earlier he got really
drunk like it's definitely really shady
yeah but it's also interesting like I
think if this it like if this was us and
that's why I chose this story like okay
you we're out with a woman first of all
you're dead what are you doing out the
woman I'll kill you and then it's like
you're holding hands with the woman or
hand on the thigh like I'm sorry you're
dead like I don't care if he was drunk
like that's weird but then I think like
if roles were reversed like if I was out
with a man a straight man I don't think
it's that weird you know like it depends
with a straight man it's like I always
think like you don't have any like
serious friends that are girls cuz
you're not allowed now you should have a
lot of them you know you're not allowed
they're gone um but like one of my best
friends the world aim is a guy he's
straight and like it's not weird but
it's your friend too like I just think
it's it's definitely it seems worse
because he's a man do you don't even
like if Jessica Biel was out with her
co-star like holding hands it could just
be like cute like friendly I don't know
it's really tough yeah it's really tough
like I would kill you if this was you
when I think of it in the lens of
Timberlake it feels like like weird yeah
so people who are like very invested in
celebrity gossip and like read blind
items they know that they definitely
have you know fidelity questionable
fidelity in their marriage like that's
what so if you're just if you're someone
who cares a lot about pop culture you
might have known then this might not
have been surprising but it is
surprising that he got caught I guess
when you're out in New Orleans I got a
bar you're not expecting to be paparazzi
like as if you were in West Hollywood
mm-hmm but I don't know sad stuff doing
the toast is weird with you because like
me and Jackie are always like fighting
for words and like you really let me
finish my sentences and like um that's
nice yeah no I'm always like talking
over Jackie it's really annoying I just
I just don't really have that much to
say on this topic I'm just like thinking
about it like yeah it's a little creepy
it's a little strange at the same time
if he was drunk and enroll I really
don't think oh he's not enroll it was
after out well I get it but like if you
spent the entire day holding hands
making out
maybe there's a sex scene in this movie
you never know you're like in that actor
mindset I'm sure that if he was in West
Hollywood and he saw his wife that
morning he's out of character but I just
feel like and I'm not saying that what
he
it wasn't wrong it was wrong I just feel
like maybe I'm not an actor I know it
seems like I am but I'm not and I feel
like once you get really in character
and then you get drunk holding hands
it's very strange
Timberlake is not Robert De Niro like
he's barely an actor he's more of a
boyband singer like he's excited to me
he's been in like four movies I don't
think you can really consider him a
method actor
he also can't hold hands yeah it's weird
I think that it would be less alarming
to me if they were caught making up I'm
thinking about this more long the
holding hands is so intimate holding
hands is very intimate but you can be
hooking up with someone and you would
never hold their hand no hole or
something about it that hands Justin
Timberlake stop that's okay the second
story is a story that is really kind of
weird but I chose it more because we had
a very similar situation happened to us
over Thanksgiving as Anna Faris because
according to Us Weekly Anna Faris was
quote saved from carbon monoxide
poisoning on Thanksgiving quote I'm
feeling very fortunate she says thank
God she's had a she's had a year mmm
feeling grateful Anna Faris had a whole
lot to be grateful thankful for this
Thanksgiving especially after she
survived a terrifying situation
involving carbon monoxide okay you'd
have to do that afternoon I say after
the Thanksgiving holiday the House Bunny
started to Twitter to tell fans about
her scary encounter with carbon monoxide
while staying with loved ones at a
rented home in Lake Tahoe California
well she rented it it wasn't her USA
Today reported that the flammable gas
leaked into the residence causing two
people to be admitted to the hospital
quote I'm not quite sure how to express
gratitude to the North Lake Tahoe fire
department the mom actress 43 tweeted on
November 29th we were saved from carbon
monoxide actress mom actress an actress
and we were saved from carbon monoxide
she said Faris regarded the incident as
a stupidly dramatic story but noted her
gratitude for coming out unharmed I'm
feeling very fortunate she added the
North Tahoe Fire Department shared
Faris's tweet while adding a statement
of their own so thankful for a happy
ending to this carbon monoxide CO
incident never assume you are safe check
your alarms whenever you travel okay so
very we did not have something similar
very sad
we had a faulty alarm I'm very sad for
Anna Faris I'm really glad that she's
okay but it just doesn't mirror
something that happened to us because we
for sure we were in Utah we run to the
house and the alarm was going off and it
was so weird and we didn't know what it
was and was like this really [ __ ]
annoying beeping sound when you hear a
beeping you always assume it's the fire
alarm the smoke detector battery you
know
we checked it wasn't and it was like the
it was like the house alarm and it's in
Co leak or something no the alert red
fire department Co so what do we think
we think that there's carbon monoxide
right that's what Co is and I saw yeah
monoxide one oxide CEO yes what was oh
and I have seen you know
Bourque a star is born where he kills
you know human suicide by running the
carbon monoxide in his truck so I know
that it can be deadly
oh I forgot that that's how he killed
himself yes have moved terrible maybe
with the dog sitting outside Oh terrible
so I took it very seriously actually I
pretty much just went downstairs and did
my own thing
but Olivia and Zach we're really all
over it and they called the fire
department we had these like you know
salt like police fire officers fire men
firemen I actually was a fire woman so
fire people come into the house and they
had their little detectors they checked
the fireplaces and it was a false alarm
but still a good lesson in fire safety I
remember I was downstairs like playing
video games shooting the [ __ ] like I
knew the fire department was there but I
knew that there wasn't any [ __ ]
carbon monoxide but that's why did you
know I just knew and Shapiro texted me
saying come upstairs the fire
department's here and like I thought
that like we were [ __ ] but we weren't
there's nothing going on they've got
like they're with their monitors making
sure that there's no carbon monoxide the
truth is you're not gonna have a carbon
monoxide leak in a new rented house and
if Aris did in Lake Tahoe
so for rich celebrities no I thought
that she took refuge to her Lake Tahoe
it happened in Lake Tahoe listen I
understand what I'm talking about when I
say you don't listen I understand
have been when she was on vacation
renting a house in Lake Tahoe very
similar say to be very similar all right
look you take back what you said and
honestly we are very thankful to the
Salt Lake City Fire Department for
hooking us up yes they coming out on a
holiday weekend fire men are and women
are such heroes how do you think such
heroes can you imagine like choosing
that as your job
no it's amazing it's so heroic so
selfless do you how do you think that
Salt Lake got its name the lake is
notoriously salty you think so
no I know it is how do you know it's
like everyone knows a more salty length
than the traditional Lake - I'm gonna
google it
I'm just saying is it the saltiest lake
or is it just Salt Lake why is so like
I'm 100% sure how somebody did it so
saltiest Lake okay when did you google
the greats okay okay there is a lake in
Salt Lake City called the Great Salt
Lake
so it's the Salt Lake City it was
originally okay so it's the city that
surrounds the Salt Lake wait how
interesting it was originally named
Great Salt Lake City by the president of
the Church of Jesus Christ latter-day
saints Brigham Young Mormon who led a
group of Mormon pioneers to the Salt
Lake Valley southeast of like Oso Salt
Lake City was gone it's named by Brigham
Young young and they told Brigham Young
University where is BYU go Cougars is
that true of course if I named random
like sports teams like from various
stuff leagues like yield 100% know the
name of the team it's tough
College is hard okay I'm gonna just
gonna I'm gonna give me three random I'm
sorry what is the name of the the CalNet
oh that's easy of the Tennessee baseball
team and I'm sure that the Choate in
there is no Tennessee in the MLS on no
but Tennessee College volunteers that's
their name the volunteers volunteers are
they volunteers I mean no I'm sure
somebody was um okay next up what is the
name of the football team of a college
of Colgate University B creds no I'll
give you a clue your t-shirt
a long city black t-shirt of another
team with readers yes the Colgate
Raiders really yes
and finally the NYU basketball team the
purple losers clothes the violets yeah
there you go losers Jesus if you play
for an MIT sports team go to a different
school well yeah obviously you're not
like trying to go anywhere with your
sports or different school maybe you got
a scholarship like maybe you're just
doing it not to get anywhere but just to
get through college I suppose um okay
well I'm glad we got to the bottom of
the Salt Lake City debacle and I think
you imagine if you like had to say that
you're like on the NYU basketball team
actually I don't give up
as a former NYU student it was very
prestigious like you could always tell
who the best book is where they were
very tall and they practicing Cole's gym
where Adam Sandler plays basketball for
fun no but that's cool you'll love Adam
Sam I love him more than anything that
doesn't mean that he is like the bar for
basketball but like in a small school
like NYU like it was pretty small school
yes it is compared to like big schools
it's not small yes like tens of
thousands of well it's not like a
liberal arts school but it's not
Michigan University you know I think
it's like 20,000 people am I wrong I
think it's less less something it's like
10 or 15 mm-hmm a lot of artsy kids yes
I took organic chemistry at NYU you did
yeah that was fun that was fun that was
exact that was the exact time when I
decided that I was not gonna be a
dentist yeah those were the days
yeah it was tough I was the only person
in my class that didn't have like pink
hair yes I said why you students we're
very self expressive and I guess that's
why we're so great now you're the purple
losers okay let's jump into the next
story which I would love to hear your
take on because it's kind of weird is
this from CNBC peloton's holiday ad made
some onlookers cringe but it won't over
all hurt the brand so obviously you know
what palitana is of course the
stationary bike they cost like three
grand people get in their house and it
has this iPad and you basically can tune
in to like live SoulCycle classes from
your house it costs $40 a month in
addition to like $3,000 bike I believe
it was bought by Equinox if they're just
killing it which is so crazy because I
don't know anyone who has one or
wouldn't even think about spending that
kind of money like you would have to
like do it's just not a city thing which
is why when Olivia mentioned that you
wanted to get a peloton we were like
what the [ __ ] that's where you're gonna
put that huge
machine now they also make treadmills
but even a treadmill like you have to be
some other kind of rich yeah I like to
have your own gym in your apartment
space not even a gym to have space for a
[ __ ] treadmill and not [ __ ] up your
apartment but I'm sure that there is
someone that has a treadmill in the
middle of the living room
totally but then it's like you have a
treadmill in your living room it's no
longer your living room so in order to
both have a nice home and a treadmill
you have to be some other level of rich
unless maybe your building is willing to
put it into their building Joe and then
you could let everyone use it and then
everybody can actually notice crazy you
will split the $40 fee well this is an
interesting thing I have seen apartment
buildings where part of their amenities
in the gym they had a full peloton room
so that you have a spinning studio and
now they have a spinning studio made
full of peloton so like people can be
doing different classes at every time it
was like 40 peloton it was like $100,000
room yeah that's a ton yeah more
actually dog day really bet you that the
peloton gave it some for free
maybe it's such a great promo honestly I
work too hard on like not sweating all
day and like smelling good to ever
actively try like some sweat in my house
you know our air conditioning is always
on like today even now it's freezing in
New York we always have air conditioning
on to the highest degree like I carry my
son Bert around like I'm not about to
just go start sweating by choice except
you've been you've been disobeying the
only house rule that we can't turn off
the air you've been turning off the air
lock really turning on the heat I only
turn off the on the heat in our living
room like we have to live it and we live
in an igloo as it should be well we have
a rule in our house you're not allowed
to turn on the air because both of us
are very averse to sweating all fear
turn off the air we are both very averse
to sweating going on the road in Jamaica
shows like I'm always [ __ ] sweating
that's why I love Sanford which is a
sponsor of our show because scent is the
most powerful sense you can have a smell
can bring on a flood of memories
influence your mood and of course
enhancer natural style that's actually
very true that scent can like bring back
memories whenever I think of truffle
that's your that pizza that you eat from
Serafina I always think of the time I
eat it and then throw up on the side of
the road in Montauk Highway in the
Hamptons on a lighter note that is a
disgusting story rose water that you use
on my face Mario Badescu my grandma used
to use rose bar so
uh-huh and that smell every single time
I smell it I remember oh that's lovely
your beautiful aunt grandma Ruthie not
aunt grandma just we're gonna say yes
grandma Ruthie
she died when I was like six years old
and the fact that I still remember that
powerful scent is amazing in literally
20 years with Sanford you can have great
taste and mix up your fragrance routine
without breaking the bank whether it's
Tom Ford Gucci or Versace sent Burt calm
keeps you smelling good month after
month said Burt is a luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
colognes they have more than 600
designer brands for you to choose from
you choose the perfume you want to try
they'll send you a 30-day supply but if
you're not sure about type of scent
you're looking for you can sort and find
your new fragrance by brand style
occasion season and more plus they have
products from other categories like
skincare wellness and makeup they carry
brands like hope re which we love the
natural deodorant that I wear that you
always steal yes yes they also carry
weight don't steal somebody's natural
deodorant it's not a quick fix this is a
dedication you got to either dedicate or
not glam glow they carry products from
Tarte glow recipe tons of others on I've
been on tempered since I started with
the toast like almost a year ago now and
I always have perfume bottles it's so
nice to have travel sized perfume
bottles that don't get taken away at TSA
and then before a shower between me and
greets like I get so sweaty at a show
then have to go to Amin Crete it's like
these people paid $75 for a Ming green I
can't smell like this no and you smell
great thank you very much I burn I wear
they have a Bulgari scent that's
delightful and they just they're adding
tons of new cents they just added a
Malin goats on I love mountain goats II
make the best chapstick they I just
headed mountain goats for exams that
they send you a smaller it's a monthly
supply of like 120 sprays and basically
that's more than enough to last you it
throughout the month and then if you
like the scent you can get an another
one that next month or order more but
it's like it's expensive perfumes but
you're getting it for subscription price
yeah it's wise like I bought that Creed
is what you bought so you didn't even
use it it was $400 I don't know what I
was thinking I'm now so deep in debt you
need scent bird and that's because I
bought this [ __ ] Creed I put it on
and then we realized that I smelled like
somebody that we knew that's all we are
getting into bed with someone I know
it's just like you know what that person
that just has like that yeah and like I
realized that I liked it that I can't
wear somebody else's
yeah I wish that I had sent bird because
then I could've gotten one now you're in
debt and I got an exclusive offer for
you just for our listeners you can get
30% off your first month today oh that's
only $10 for your first designer
fragrance go to Sandburg comm / Steen or
just use our code Steen for 30% off your
first month again that's scent bird scen
TBI RDECOM / Steen ste and for you to
try your first perfumer cologne for just
$10 sign-on smell amazing nice ok back
to the story so but that is a nice
product so basically this peloton
controversy goes like this yes peloton
is a maker is from CMU say that maker of
high-end home fitness equipment is
getting criticized for a new holiday ad
that implores viewers to give the gift
of peloton but the flap probably won't
hurt the company despite onlookers
complaining about what they saw as
undertones of sexism and classism in the
ad
indeed peloton stock rose 4.6 percent on
Monday after the Thanksgiving weekend
when much of the criticism surface and
is now up more than 25 percent since the
stock debuted in September as of Tuesday
afternoon peloton stock was down more
than 9 percent amid brokers dr. ok
whatever but I want to tell you what
that is in the ad a woman receives a
peloton as a Christmas gift from her
husband okay
so already I just think like a man
giving a woman a peloton it's like maybe
she asked for it okay
then it documents her usage of the bike
which costs two thousand two hundred and
forty five dollars with a monthly $39
membership fee to access classes the
woman in the ad remarks she didn't
realize how much this would change her
according to I spot TV the ad first
friend November 4th and has run more
than seven thousand times
accounting for an estimated thirteen
million dollars in spending I mean you
spend thirteen million dollars in your
ad only runs seven thousand times on TV
TVs expensive man that's crazy on social
media son commented that the woman's
before-and-after looks were identical or
remark that it was strange that a spouse
seemed to be pursuing his partner with
the gift to lose some weight these are
some things people said online the lady
in the peloton ad is already toned and
fit in the before part making in order
to believe she would be nervous about a
basic spin class though that's probably
the least weird thing about the ad
another person
nothing says maybe you should lose a few
pounds like gifting you're already
rail-thin life partner a peloton
some commented oh how nervous and
unhappy the woman seemed to be while
documenting her work out okay so there's
the lady looks so weird this is another
tweet I'm nervous
I've never been the stationary bike it
is the scariest thing I've ever done in
my entire life even worse than giving
birth I'm terrified please help me
peloton others said the ad was just too
over-the-top aspirational give him the
set given the setting of the home
peloton could seriously save a ton of
marketing money by showing a text-only
commercial with the verbiage rich people
[ __ ] that won't fit anywhere in your
measly 2,000 square foot house that's
true so I guess people were upset that
like they documented the transformation
before-and-after but the woman was like
incredibly thin before and incredibly
thin after it was just like I guess a
little tone deaf look Pellatt peloton is
a tone deaf company if you have some
very very large woman being gifted a
peloton then it's like and worse so I
give the gift to a fat woman yes you're
they're screwed either way what I really
feel bad for are the people that have
been making stationary bikes for a
hundred years and all of a sudden
peloton people are just like oh it's new
stationary bikes forever like what's the
difference because I can look in this
virtual thing I've had glass like it's
not it doesn't make that's a terrible
that's a good call many people came
before peloton that just yeah but I hear
what you're saying like they couldn't
have won either way because if they had
done the opposite it would have been
more tone-deaf but there have been
commercials for like Jillian Michaels is
always on those weird like aerobic like
like you can make a commercial for an
actually infomercial though no it's not
their regular commercials for it and
like you can make a commercial for an
expensive at home fitness machine and
not offend people there is a way to do
it because Jillian Michaels has been
doing it for years
I suppose look I think that they just
know exactly who their demographic is
yeah when he charged that amount of
money and charge that monthly
subscription and are putting yourself in
luxury buildings in Manhattan you are
clearly trying to appeal to a very very
specific perfect and that's why it's not
shocking that the controversy even
affected didn't affect that their stocks
there they don't care it's literally a
rich person thing and not only that you
got to be rich and skinny so it's like
literally it's 1% of the 1% actually
most 50% of the 1% and great if you get
50% of the 1% to spend $3,000 a year
plus $40 a month you
no totally I just can't think of
anything I would ever want less than a
pillow job didn't I tell you you
couldn't call from the show oh yeah I'm
sorry by the way that new you said I
couldn't clear my throat yeah
and you've been good I have no I like
you can't control when you coughed no
but it's very dusty in here isn't it
dusty
no everywhere you go you think it's
dusty because you're there's a lot of
dust no there's not there's this is a
clean of studio and all of an Hatton's
telephone is very interesting it's so
big I know and I just can't imagine like
wanting one no like it is really for
such a specific person you have such a
big home in suburbia you have nothing
all of the women from Desperate
Housewives would have a peloton oh my
god because when you say it's so weird
peloton peloton I don't think so I think
it's peloton you're saying it like
skeletons know like peloton peloton like
Pelikan peloton peloton yeah thank you
oh my god you're bothering me fella talk
peloton not Helen it's a civic person
you have to have so much space you don't
know what to do with it yes and then you
have to have so much money that you
don't know what to do it you also need
to have like so much time to be like
[ __ ] so cycling every day
it also doesn't make any sense Equinox
is cheaper well so Equinox which now
owns SoulCycle
I do believe also bought peloton for
four billion dollars but why does it
like it really is truly a suburbia thing
because it must be it takes you so long
to get to an equinox well I guess if
you're the type of person who would soul
cycle every day at 13 my calculator out
it's $35 to do a cell cycle and let's
say you're doing $35 seven to six days a
week you take one day you can take
cycling there's juice so you could if
here if you soul cycle every day you
could spend eleven grand a year on soul
cycle that's crazy
nice Wow versus the peloton about three
grand right I guess I mean this is truly
just a rich person problem one like I
said I just can't relate to but like no
but it's also a very specific it's
suburbia rich I don't think it has to do
with silver because if you're rich in
New York you have place to put it
no but you have to be really rich you
have to be able to have the gym in your
apartment no do you know that has a gym
in their apartment no nobody but if
you're really rich you just have a spare
bedroom and put your pallet on in it
yeah that is so losery
yeah
you know three blocks soon equinox this
whole thing on the bike this whole thing
is loose right or you can take a city
bike for three dollars by the way just
yeah this is so strange
yeah tone-deaf hate to see it hate to
see it
let's move on because I picked this
story specifically for you because I
know we keep talking about our vacation
but over the course of our vacation we
we had a kind of a renaissance with the
game Monopoly as kids we all played it
and think about by the way who loves
monopoly pushing it forever Ben loves it
so much and he finally got us all to
play while we were away and we just fell
in love with Monopoly like it was these
like games that went on for hours and it
was so heated it was really like
exciting I don't think I've ever played
it as an adult the right way like as a
kid you never bought houses like you
didn't really understand usually you
just pass go and take your $200 but now
we played it like a fully as adults like
what the rules and was actually like a
lot of fun kind of like an educational
game I love it so I becomes very sad
though like you're winning everybody
houses hotels boardwalk and then all of
a sudden you land on boardwalk one time
in the hotel you have to start
mortgaging your property selling off
your homes you go from four homes to
three to two to one and true you truly
if you lose you after a long game like a
four-hour game if you lose you leave
that game feeling like you just lost
some serious real money it's really
depressing speaking of real money oh so
that's the story okay so this is from
eonline John Travolta is so rich he
plays Monopoly with real money when John
Travolta passes go he actually collects
$200 during an appearance on went an
appearance on Wednesdays The Late Late
Show the grease alumni in a completely
random chair by the way the grease oh
yeah I thought that was like a weird
that's his tag on what else would he be
known for I don't know everything
hairspray know what else is in season
how is he so rich now that I think about
it he's in the most iconic movie ever
that somehow was blue like you Oh
Saturday Night Fever no with the drugs
all the drugs what Samuel Jackson what
drugs I'll google it Pope thank you
thank you
pulp fiction but do you make so much
money from like a few good yeah yeah
fiction
okay holy smokes
movie okay so he revealed that he when
he plays Monopoly he switches out the
fake money for real money yes he has
that much expendable cash fellow guests
on the couch Aaron taylor-johnson and
Sam taylor-johnson were the ones to
bring the classic board game into the
conversation speaking of their holiday
traditions the couple told host James
Corden that when they play Monopoly
during the holiday season it usually
lasts three days and gets highly
competitive that's so funny
then John Travolta chimed in with his
own idea for upping the stakes
did you ever replace the money with real
money he asked without missing a beat
Sam said no an actor responded and
that's the way to do it and then saying
what we're all thinking James crypt John
we get it you're rich we get it
needing all the possible T about this
the host then asked hang on you've
played Monopoly with real cash his
expensive habit got even less relatable
when the pulp fiction actor responded
yes but look it's $20 it's $100 I think
the totality is $2,000 I think if you
replace the whole thing by the way it's
not know you everyone gets $59 but then
with free parking and the bang bang yeah
I watched a YouTube video and so me and
Zach huan'er manes we were so obsessed
with monopoly that we started watching
monopoly strategy videos on YouTube and
one of the videos was this youtuber that
had five people from like I guess there
were big fans of his vlog common playing
monopoly for real money oh well and you
realize that yeah they start with $59
each the bank needs to have so much
money the winner walks away with like 11
grand Wow because you have to have AI
for free parking you have to have a
single tiny Pascal the properties yeah
it's a lot of money wow that's crazy I
mean actually it sounds so fun it's so
fun but like but I think it would be
just as fun if you lowered the whole
thing to $150 yes they should come up
with a version actually that's made to
be played with real real money where
every person can buy in for like a
hundred dollars and all the prices have
now been lower than adjusted so that
like you can you could either lose your
hundred or make five hundred yeah
like poker exactly it's so fun so fun I
need someone to do the math and like
change all the prices of the properties
you just you can just divide everything
by ten that's so cool we should try that
should
so then completely blown away the host
James Corden asked John Travolta what
are you like in Vegas and he goes I
don't do that
he doesn't gamble I think I mean he's a
Scientologist I don't know if you're
allowed to gamble but this does sound
like ambush the same exact thing but
just not properly for money I'm really
surprised that they still like John
Travolta like go on Lane I chose and
pretend that he's not like a meteor
because he's like a big one
you see yeah like it hasn't been bought
to the for frying up like many young men
have accused him of so they're masseuses
actually read one of the young men yeah
well ever what most people know well I'm
not about to out someone but most people
now um I read one of the accounts of one
of the young men who came out against
John Travolta and it was like
heartbreaking he was like a young guy he
wouldn't he's like a freelance masseuse
in Philadelphia and he got a call asking
if he would do like a celebrity client
he was like oh my god of course and he
was like so excited and they were just
like so many weird things that happened
like leading up to the the massage and
then the massage happened and like it
was just wildly inappropriate like he
was touching
Charles was touching him like it was and
and a few people have come out against
him but like he pretty much stays under
the radar he's got that Scientology like
protection bubble that is so crazy no I
know and like you didn't even know that
right no but it's just like I don't get
it
it goes back to Justin of course it's
totally different but do Justin
Timberlake and John Travolta not think
that when they do weird things that
people are gonna find out about no it's
like even if you're a regular person you
do something weird everyone you know is
gonna know like you're a celebrity now
like people are gonna talk about you
tenfold huh shocking also being a
freelance masseuses very people with a
very oh yeah very and she can tell you
that happened with Paulo in the first
season Paulo grabbed her ass it did when
he was dating Rachel yes but also when
she got that big corporate job in the
masseur place she she sold her soul sold
her soul but then made out with that guy
that ended up being married yeah yeah
goes both ways my friends I'm also this
is a great question for you because we
spoke about this on the toast the other
day asking if if you could have any job
in the world which job would you want to
have the least and then most people
answer it's like shoveling [ __ ] at the
circus like sanitation worker even
though they have great benefits and make
a lot of money my answer always been the
same it's that I would literally never
ever ever want to work as like a runner
on a beach who like sets up chairs and
towels so hot ya know there is one job
in the world that is the worst job in
the world and
I can't believe that people said
shoveling [ __ ] at the circus and a
garbage man a garbage man or a woman
waiting like 80 to 90 grand has great
benefits for the government they have
amazing health insurance it's okay it's
smelly sure that eventually you get used
to it get used to the smell there is no
worse job I'm so excited to hear entire
world I'd prefer to be in prison not
solitary confinement because I think
it's the same thing a tollbooth operator
might be the worst job on the planet but
you also work for the government it
doesn't matter so you've been those
benefits to no one yeah you talk to
people when they come through no you
don't ya know you've literally it's not
it's not the old days it's easy pass oh
there's no talking you sit alone in
silence on the highway for 10 straight
hours that's a good point
I love that you had an answer for that
that's why I've thought of that before
yeah very lonely life it is yeah also
the thought of being in solitary
confinement in President is also my
worst nightmare that's but it seems very
similar to me do you ever see the
episode of SVU
when Stabler I think it is that goes
undercover and it gets put in solitary
confinement and they they leave him in
for a day because they know he's
undercover so they only put him in for
one day and he comes out here and he's
like screaming I can't believe you left
me in there for a week there's only a
day mm-hmm so scary that's like my worst
staring at [ __ ] white walls oh my god
not even white they're like Doody Brown
is it are they well I don't know I've
never been to prison but I imagine
they're not like sparkly white sorry if
you guys see me like flexing my calf
it's burning yes for my workout it's
very it's very sore um our fifth and
final story is always a little okay you
don't know that we do this because I
know you never watch I do so you know
what I'm about to do yeah okay then do
it with me wait to our fifth and final
story is a little bit of business it's
business big news I chose it it's
actually like a little tech news and as
always our business is sponsored and
today it's brought to you by legacy box
in amazing subscription service that
more sorry not subscription service
service that many more people need to
know about because I can't believe that
we've lived with this problem as
Millennials like our whole lives and I
know you can relate
legacy box you can get a lifetime of old
family memories videotapes photos and
more digitized to a thumbdrive
cloud download or
dvd to share and enjoy for future
generations this is perfect to get for
the holiday it's like if you have a mom
or an aunt or grandma who it's like tons
of old like VHS is or like camcorder
tapes just sitting around and you have
absolutely no idea what to do with them
send in your legacy box they will
digitize them for you and that's such a
nice gift to get for someone you really
care about the process from start to
finish is so easy you go online purchase
the box that you need they send you a
legacy box kit you fill it with all your
media slap on the prepaid mailing label
and then send it back to them they make
it so easy for you in a couple weeks you
will get all your originals back plus
perfectly preserved digital copies ready
to watch share and relive legacy box
keep you informed throughout the process
with regular email updates and over
700,000 families have trusted legacy box
with their prized possessions they've
been in business for over a decade and
is the industry leader in a
professionally digitized antiquated
media growing up we had so many VHS
tapes in our house and like honestly we
left them in storage like what do you do
with that kind of stuff like you we went
to Best Buy one year and we got this
whole converter it was so torturous just
to watch one home video and actually
think this is such a good idea like is
right like how sweet I feel like your
mom without that as a gift the photos in
particular I think that my parents have
an entire closet full of just printed
photos of photos of photo books it's
also like what do you do with like your
grandparents photos I know there's a lot
of photos yeah and like have it on a
thumb drive yeah it would be it would be
cool I'm okay so actually think it might
be a great gift from your mom I don't
know if she's watching with spoiler
alert even we might get this for you
because they've a Black Friday Cyber
Monday deal
forget about door Busters head to legacy
box.com for their best deal of the year
your life's biggest moments call for
some big savings you can get 60 percent
off Black Friday and Cyber Monday orders
well everyone else is going crazy trying
to get the best deals with this Black
Friday and Cyber Monday you can relax
knowing you saved big on all your
memories after all technology can be
replaced with the next best thing but a
lifetime of one-of-a-kind memories that
is irreplaceable order your legacy box
today to take advantage of legacy boxes
Black Friday Cyber Monday sale for a
limited time take an unprecedented
unprecedented 60 percent off go to
legacy box comm / toast to get 60
percent off your first order save your
time and memories go to legacy box.com /
toast and save 60 percent I think that's
a great
thing and then once you get your
digitized photos you can upload them to
Instagram leading us to our fifth and
final story from CNN business Instagram
and I brought this for you because you
are like our resident like tech
correspondent certainly um what you say
certainly okay thanks it's certainly
Instagram will now ask users to provide
their age nearly a decade after its
launch Instagram is finally taking the
basic step of asking people signing up
for the service to provide their age in
an attempt to better young better
protect younger users starting Wednesday
the photo sharing service will ask new
users for their date of birth when an
account is created wow I can't believe
that when we signed up for Instagram we
didn't need to put in our date of birth
I'll share my let me just get through
all the details previously Instagram
users were required to confirm their
ages were 13 or older when signing up
but they didn't have to provide an exact
birthday Instagram is long valued
anonymity including not requiring people
to use real names however as with any
other online service it's possible users
can lie about their age in order to join
quote asking for this information will
help prevent underage people from
joining Instagram help us keep young
people safer and enable more
age-appropriate
experiences overall Instagram said it
would use age information to recommend
younger people opt for more privacy
settings such as allowing new message
requests only from people they follow
the photo sharing service has been
criticized for not checking kids age
which potentially runs the risk of
exposing younger users to inappropriate
content and also allows Instagram to
collect data about kids under the age of
13 and the child's online privacy
protection act limits how a company can
collect data about anyone under 13 I
didn't know that that was even a thing
how interesting neither did I what are
your thoughts here so this is a load of
[ __ ] and I'll say that it's a load
of [ __ ] because Instagram knows
exactly how old every single person is
that is on the platform that has a
Facebook data exactly what their real
name is if they have a Facebook and
anybody that has an Instagram business
account knows that we have analytics on
how old our audiences are simply because
they proxy it off of Facebook so the one
thing that I do I it seems to me like
they got in some type of hot water
yeah but child by the child protection
and that they now need to which makes
sense like if a ten-year-old can just go
and follow worldstar because his friends
like
there's cool sneakers and all of a
sudden that midnight
worldstar yeah we're all sorry after
dark so I had to follow them yes I mean
it's porn it's part it's porn at night
yeah they are a 24-hour news service yes
beginning in the day with your you're
like normal PG yeah sneaker news and at
the end of the day it's all hoes it's a
little annoying I mean I see both sides
of it because I think Facebook is so
strict with who can sign up for their
platform like we made in it's a Facebook
account called head toasts that we could
monitor all of our groups through and
kind of just be like the let us together
and Facebook took it down and it's like
we are not the problem like we are not
you know loitering and like you know
trying to get kids like we're just
trying to you know what anything like
we're just doing our business and like
that got taken down like I do I think
and there you need to provide six forms
of identification proving that your
first name is head son our first [ __ ]
name so it was just like too strict but
I do think Instagram is like way too
loose with it like the fact that like
and like that just leads to more
cyberbullying and like so much trolling
because literally no one knows anything
about you because you can be so
anonymous which is also what's nice you
know and that's a there's the life in a
middle ground
people like to be able to have social
media when they're not social people
they like to be lurkers that being said
like those people with like the little
anime thing like telling me that like my
mother sucks [ __ ] in hell like yeah
wishes that all of my family died in the
Holocaust those people are never on real
accounts like every now and then I'll
get like a really mean troll message
from someone's real Instagram I'm like
damn that's [ __ ] brave of you
totally nine times out of ten it's an
account that follows your people has
zero followers and doesn't have a
picture like there was somebody
yesterday or two days ago that commented
on one of my posts be quiet Jill Wow and
like under it I wrote like I love to
start my day with anti-semitism but like
I clicked on it it's like a picture of
him and his wife yes see that's [ __ ]
weird it's like do you do you know that
I can now find out exactly who you are
and tell your boss that you're
anti-semitic great like be careful don't
you like it
I saw you ever like leaving a comment
like a racist con
or something on someone's Instagram I
would [ __ ] call you and be like what
the [ __ ] are you doing novalee so it's
obvious that this person who was taking
a picture with his wife like has nobody
in this life that cares about him and
that's actually really sad no it also
means that he's an anti somatic prick
and that's sort of the other point it's
like I would never leave a racist
comment because I don't think racist
thoughts that's true but like anybody
that has the balls to say be quiet Jew
on somebody's post what's wrong with you
you live in a totally different world
you do like where your means people I'm
sorry that that happened to you bullies
I'm sorry that that happened to you I
love you and I think you're a great
chill thank you a big smart one I am a
big smart you the best with really curly
hair I am it's not that girl it's pretty
curly that's nice I'm going for the sort
of that green yeah yeah yes season one
its montage I'm really just like cool
loose like don't care that much for like
where's sue because like um if you guys
have any questions for Ben feel free to
drop them on the YouTube stream because
that is all the content we had for today
wow I can't believe we did it click on
such short notice because shucked and
jived recommend drivers are you watching
any TV that you want to discuss am i
watching any TV no okay I see in the
feed right now you look very thin I do
yeah you look great so this is it a
little up yeah you look great you look
better no I think you look lost our
figure and Ben's wearing a suit you guys
like I said because we went to a risk
today what TV are you watching I don't
know are you started the affair here's
the thing I don't get to watch TV yeah
that's it I get to start shows I never
know how they end you finished them
without me because you want to know why
like you you have a very full and robust
life and it's like my job is to watch TV
and recap it here so it's like I'll
start something with you and if we go at
your pace like I'll never finish it now
I have to come here on the toast and
tell the trusters whether or not it's
worth investing their time in I
understand but so that is why I watch a
ton of Modern Family a ton of friends
it's just like [ __ ] that I can just like
watch and be brain dead can you admit
that when we first met you didn't like
friends and now you do yeah because I've
been brainwashed oh my god okay I got
some questions for you from the inside
show this is from Liz height when can we
expect more what are you nuts episodes
so I was actually just talking about
this with you at lunch lunch breakfast
it was breakfast today the only reason
why I haven't released more what are you
nuts videos is because I simply do not
have enough guests here in family I went
through the family I have a very very
prestigious special guest for my next
episode of what are you nuts but after
that it's like there are just so many
people that I trust to be funny enough
to come up with it something that's nuts
not everyone is a star so we've decided
is that I'm going to do them solo
sometimes because I have plenty of
things plenty of grievances to air all
the time it's a quick sneak peek what is
up with broccoli rabe
do you know seriously yeah it doesn't
make any sense
there's broccoli there's broccolini and
then there's broccoli rabe broccoli rabe
he's bitter broccoli why would you opt
you have two choices an apple or a
bitter apple a juicy apple or a bitter
apple why would you people choose the
bitter apple
I mean nuts Rob I've never eaten
broccoli or our broccoli rabe so I can't
relate but good for you honey I'm just
saying oh no I soon they're coming more
questions from Gracie Smith Ben where do
you shop for clothes
my husband style is trash it's time to
refresh if your husband style is trash
that's on your husband that is the truth
any woman that tries to dress a man and
change a man she can help him she can
try and help him I just you have to want
it for yourself like I don't dress like
this because you want me to I dress like
I enjoy fashion I enjoy clothing I go I
buy it I have plenty of friends that
don't give a [ __ ]
hmm if you're looking for store
recommendations Bloomingdale's is a
great place it's a great story if so
many says I love nails if he's bigger
than me
Roth Rothman's what's a call a Roth is a
great sort to downtown no no he knows
about this
Rochester big and tall Rochester big and
tall your door if you're a husky man
it's designer clothing so they make I
didn't even know Ralph Lauren made sizes
but beyond 3x because they don't sell it
at Bloomingdale's but they sell it at
Rochester big and tall it's like a fancy
a store because they're they saw
everything so they were sure stuff
fortunately unfortunately I'm not there
yet I don't need to shop there yet but
if you do nothing to be ashamed of they
have great stuff yeah
okay we got a lot of questions about
your ear how is it healing everyone
knows if you watch my Instagram live the
other day Ben had the biggest blackhead
in his ear of all time that has been
growing in there for almost a year and I
extracted it with my special tools that
I bought on Amazon you did you did a
great job thank you my ear is totally
fine I have perfect skin folks that is
the that is the god honest truth I was
born with just perfect skin I get a
pimple once in a blue moon sure and the
only reason why I have pimples is
because my wife takes her dirty ass
[ __ ] fingernails oh my just my black
it's my fault
shirts dirt into my skin No so if you're
wondering why I had a blackhead in the
first place it's probably because she
was picking my ear a couple of years ago
and the dirt got infected and went under
the skin became a black okay I just have
to say at the rate of but you're
answering these questions we're gonna
get through like three questions it's
just like simple questions um I was just
sorry I'm going to that one wants to
know what's your biggest fear that's a
great question
if you want to know mine my biggest fear
is being alone I don't really like I'm
not scared of I don't know I have no
clue okay um what's your biggest regret
in life from a lot of Carter I don't
really have regrets either I don't know
every like it's gonna be cheesy but like
everything bad in life you learn from
and then you become a better person so I
don't really have any any regrets
pouring in so you know how many regrets
and you none the biggest fear yeah but
you give me some real questions here
with some depth I actually know what do
something with them I can give you the
biggest regret of your life or what
should be the biggest regret of your
life what is it when we were dating for
like a year we were on 72nd Street and
third Avenue do you know what I'm about
to say yeah we were standing on the
corner when all of a sudden corruption
occurred we saw TD Bank getting robbed
oh yes it was so crazy this guy ran out
on foot there was smoke everywhere we
got more than a year okay I'm not it
doesn't matter and this guy ran out he
dropped the money and ran because the
money had like a smoke bomb on it and
there was like dollar bills
strewn about third Avenue with red
stamps and red holes in them remember
you robbed an ATM and the police pulled
up and they were like where did he go
and I was like he was wearing a polka
polo he went north on Third Avenue
they're like all right get in the car
let's go and I was like and you were
like Claudia
we are not going and I was like what I'm
a snapchat the whole experience and
you're like Claudia we're not going I'm
like okay and then I listened to you so
that was my biggest regret in the world
was listening to your dumb ass and your
biggest regret should be ever telling me
not to get in the movies guys we
should've gone in the police car okay I
do agree the reason why I don't have too
many regrets is because I don't put
myself in bad situations if something
seems Shady like there's a bank robber
I'm not gonna go like looking at the
bank robber like who bank robber or what
are you up to
like no you go rob your bank I'm gonna
live my life and not be near bank i
watch SVU I'm a good eyewitness he was
very thin tall purple polo light washed
jeans and brown sneakers yep I gave her
great just rounded up a bank robber I
wonder if they ever caught him oh yeah
he had red dial I assure positive they
caught him you think he was on foot he
was very fast yeah I think he was maybe
Kenyan because he was running very fast
he was yeah okay a few more questions
besides Claudia which sister are you
most similar to hmm which sister am i
most similar today yeah like who do you
relate to the most it changes all the
time I gotta be honest at different
points I've related to sisters more and
less I used to really relate to Jackie
now I don't really relate to her at all
she doesn't really drink now so like we
can't relate no but like me and Jackie
are the same age I don't know if
everybody knows that all right yeah like
who eggs were in the same gray same
grade like very similar taste in music
but now she's like gone more country and
a little bit less punk I I really told
um if you could join any punk band which
band would it be ooh
we know you're being Third Eye Blind
know a hundred percent blink 182 there's
just no question they are just [ __ ]
icons this is from a youtuber named SLC
what
your last meal on earth B I want
appetizer main meal dessert and a drink
my last meal on earth okay so it's
dinner if it's appetizer we're thinking
dinner I think dinner or like yeah yeah
okay the meal is sushi it is just by far
my favorite I love it the most I make it
incredibly gluttonous everybody's like
CG you're not gonna be thorough well
you've never [ __ ] that sushi with me
sir you have some kind of a sushi near
its art are delicious get a side of
spicy mayonnaise fantastic then you go
in you have some traditional roles some
pieces you cap it off with what kind of
dessert I love a good cookie like a half
baked chocolate chip cookie not like a
hard one not AIT's like one thing you
took out of the oven a little bit early
and what are you drinking with this meal
ooh it's so tough
probably Diet Coke from the fountain
from a bottle from a can from the
fountain the best fountain has to be a
premier fountain some fountains are just
black they don't cut it I also love a
good iced tea I also love a good hot tea
I'm gonna go with the dico fountain um
then have you ever cheated or been
cheated on
no and no good um thank God
I don't think been what is your favorite
quality about Theo this is from Morgan
for a great question
Theo has a heart of pure gold if I
didn't stop him he would lick the toes
of every single homeless man Hindman
happen yeah he doesn't see like you see
anything he just sees pure love the
happiness he doesn't see danger he
doesn't see anything he is just but that
being said he's smart enough to know
when something's wrong like sometimes
like he won't walk over greats he's a
smart boy he's a he's afraid of things
but he's not afraid of people he is a
sense of danger which is so crazy
because I would say maybe in the chewy
and 1/2 years we've had him maybe three
times has he woken up in the middle the
night and started barking which is
really
creepy and the dark like makes me think
that like there's a ghost
he he sees I've had things with that
like that with him before he stops his
tracks and just looks at things like he
he definitely knows bidding are you
spinning I yeah I just saw your spin
spinning no shows not that high quality
good but he is not afraid of any animal
any like I if I was him we walked past
the horses in Central Park all the time
wouldn't you be free work yeah it's a
dog that's like 8,000 times your size we
have a dog in our building that is a
[ __ ] horse a small child could ride
this dog it's crazy I forget the name of
the dog Jupiter it's a very famous dog
no like the but Theo and him went nose
to nose the other day he's so generous
like you're so kind
he loves everyone some definitely the
best quality that mrs. Hart okay so
thank you so much for hosting that was
such a great episode if anyone wants to
know more about Ben follow them at boy
with no job he also has a personal
Instagram big soft sof f we've got a lot
of questions about merch reminder that
tomorrow is our big merch drop it's
happening at 1 p.m. 1 p.m. Eastern Time
so that's 10 a.m. Pacific time and then
you have to figure out your other time
zones I can't figure that out for you
it's dropping at 1 p.m. a lot of
questions about prices it's all of our
usual pricing there's some new items I
don't think anything is priced over $100
yeah we'll be revealing all the looks
all the items today on our Instagram so
make sure you're following the morning
toast Instagram I'm gonna be in Canada
tomorrow and Tarrytown Westchester on
Saturday tickets are available at Carl's
no job hum for both shows I'm also gonna
be in Chicago at the end of this month
doing three shows there I believe
they're sold out I'm not entirely sure
Verona New York I'm gonna be heading
upstate tickets available no job com
Kansas City Missouri angle would New
Jersey Atlantic City New Jersey tickets
available do you know where they're
available then girl with no job calm and
all capping off where the Beacon Theater
but that's of course been sold out sorry
second I mean I guess you could maybe a
scalper or stop it we love you guys
thank you so much for shucking and
jiving with us this morning here at the
morning
millennial Morning Show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so please feel feeli
feel free to subscribe to us on youtube
give this video a thumbs up leave a
comment we're also available as a
podcast pretty much anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's Spotify iTunes
stitcher Public Radio IR radio cast box
all the apps so subscribe to us wherever
you listen to podcasts leave us a five
star review in a comment about how
stunning smart and skinny we are we love
you guys so much have a great Thursday
we will see you tomorrow on Friday merch
day gotta get down on Friday
you